not only are diesel prices at a new
record high but they're actually
predicting diesel shortages
so
i'd like to imagine that we're headed
towards a future where we have this you
know one step closer towards utopia
poverty is being eliminated but if
there's no diesel
nothing's being sent to your house your
local grocery store is going to have no
meat and you better start figuring out
what you would do in a circumstance so
what is the reason behind the diesel
storage i'm actually curious that's the
thesis of the article but i want to know
why i i think it's just
they say to drop in production
drop in production increase demand in a
drop in production they're saying a
shortage may be next
and i think joe biden said we don't get
enough truckers man you know it's like
someone already super chatted us and
we'll read in a bit they said that the
cost of fuel is greater than what they
make so they quit
oh boy right well okay scarcity of a
important commodity i guess that's not
good
but i mean i'm still you know you
there's still a good reason to be
generally optimistic about the us
economy in terms of like finding
alternatives i mean the higher price one
thing gets the more people figure out a
way to use different resources or come
up with a technological innovation you
know so you're not shorting it that's
what you're telling us no i'm not gonna
i'm not sure
has been a loser's bet for a hundred
years right like that's if you're
talking about what has what has been a
bad idea shorting the american economy
and i got an extra bad idea i'd say i
don't i think
i think
betting on the amer uh american economy
is the best thing you can do
because in the event the american
economy collapses and you live inside of
it who cares right oh you're in trouble
i'm all in like yeah no exactly like the
people who had it's sort of you know
this is kind of like the classic answer
to people who are like buying gold it's
like well why are you buying gold it's
like well the economy is going to
collapse i'm like golly gonna you want
to buy bullets and and like spam you
know right like
you know if that's if that that's your
hedge against if you're trying to hedge
against that you're not hedging with the
writers i always i always found this
funny when people you know alex jones
would always talk about buying gold and
stuff and then i was like what am i
going to do with gold in an apocalypse
am i going to be walking down the street
and some guy's going to have like a
sandwich and i'm like i'll give you a
gold ford it'll be like i don't want to
carry that it's heavy you could make
batteries make a grill sure sure you're
gonna make a batter you're gonna there's
gonna be a guy who's gonna have he's
gonna have a wild boar and you're gonna
say
i have a raw piece of gold you can make
a battery with he's gonna go that's a
good point i will give you no your
baghdad battery i was talking about have
you ever seen if you were walking down
the street in the apocalypse and a guy
on the left
has has a bottle of water and the guy on
the right has food or should i believe
you better if if you're walking on the
street and there's a guy with a you know
us a big sandwich
and you have gold and the guy next to
you as a bottle of water who do you
think's getting piece of that sandwich
yeah yeah once basic needs are met it
comes down to the metals like copper no
copper because you make bronze with it
to make weapons stabby weapons
the water bottle is going to walk up to
the guy with the sandwich and say i'll
give you some water for some of your
sandwich it'll be like deal and you'll
walk up i got gold and they'll be like i
can't eat that and the other guy's gonna
be like i got this knife and you're like
ah so that's why that's where the metal
was for weapons so it's like and
generally i think you know you don't
need to hedge that much against
apocalypse one that's extraordinarily
unlikely and two you know
the id's the idea that you would find
the correct hedge is level well no no it
is uh hedging for the apocalypse is
moving at the middle of nowhere getting
chickens getting some of the emergencies
what you guys are doing yeah actually
yeah you know what you're not invited
now after all this right right
options no you know what sheamus you're
not invited that's absolutely ridiculous
no i'll build my own con that's fine
yeah
i'm looking you think you think we need
a cartoon we're going to start guests
bro i'm going to run concerts
we don't need a cartoonist we need a
lawyer you're saying that now
i mean to be honest though like a lawyer
would probably handle negotiations
between other tribes better than like
it'd be a pretty good job
like figuring out yeah new dispute
resolution mechanisms that aren't war
that seems like that's they won't be
interested man uh i think what's gonna
happen you'll go around to other
people's compounds and be like actually
we have copywritten that method of
collecting food you owe us ten percent
yeah it would actually be a funny bit
where it's like we choose the lawyer
over the animator in the apocalypse and
then the lawyer is like i've negotiated
this really great treaty that will
benefit all of us and they're like kill
him and then the animator walks up and
is like i drew a picture of you and your
mom together and i was like
what we're missing is the synergies of
them because if will brings up the
boring law sheamus can animate it make
it fun for people to understand there
you go insult their intelligence at the
same time exactly
some good news i looked up how to make
your own bio diesel it's actually i
don't think it's very complicated i mean
there is actually one good financial met
like bet on the american economy like do
you think europe's better than us like
they're not they're they're they they
have worse rule law they have work
they're way more socialist do you think
like china is going to be a smarter bet
possibly but
china's not nearly as innovative as we
are as a general matter yeah but they
are willing to enslave people
right but then that's also like an
independent problem that's a good reason
that's an
both on a practical and an ethical level
right ethically that's wrong but
practically also that's a recipe for
instability uh yeah what's their ekg
score what is that like esg esg what's
their what's worse in china china's
gonna have a 97 or something like that
america's america's still the best place
in the world to do business it's still
like has the most innovation still has
the most like well
maybe maybe red states it's like we're
you know the problems we're dealing with
are almost like we just
we're worried that government is going
to you know outrage essentially be so
bad that it overwhelms the benefits that
innovation and our general economy will
bring and they're
they're making it closer than we want
but i would still i'd still bet on the
economy i'll tell you this new jersey
these blue states are really destroying
themselves yeah no no for real so when
we when we were headquartered in new
jersey
i was reading about you know opportunity
expansion
and they said they had a millennial
brain drain millennials
uh
as soon as i shouldn't even say
millennial it was it's young people in
general as soon as they become adults
they get out
there is zero opportunity and the reason
for it is they're anti-business
new jersey is very very anti-business
period so when i was looking at
expanding in new york i'm like i look
you know there's an opportunity here you
got new york up here you got philly here
you got you know pennsylvania right
across the street and then i was like
wow those are the laws and those are the
taxes
let's leave did you ever investigate why
you think that is
it's because i think um
people on the left vote based on their
feelings and not based on what makes
sense
and so they end up saying things like
hey we need more tax money to pay for
schools
because more schools and more money in
schools means kids will be better off so
we need we need to raise the taxes to
get more tax money and then what ends up
happening when you raise taxes tax
revenue goes down and businesses flee
and then all of a sudden you end up with
poverty and corruption and broken cities
and they're like we don't understand we
tax to the rich it's like and then the
rich left what do you think is going to
happen and i mean i mean i think
competition between like jurisdictions
is is different now right if you think
about who is new jersey competing with
well they're competing with the state of
new york in the state of pennsylvania
basically and those states are not
really super business friendly either uh
in their own right so they probably
didn't think like oh you know we can
just
be a little better than those two states
and and not lose business across the
rivers new jersey should be one of the
best states for business and wealthiest
states in the country it's in a perfect
position because it's got you've you're
you're you've got new york right there
you've got pennsylvania right there
right so you have you have a real
opportunity for the people of philly and
south jersey to be like we do we we sell
our product in philly but we manufacture
and run our business in jersey because
they're better for us you've got a real
opportunity for the same thing we said
in new york we operate out of north
jersey and then we do business in in new
york because the customers are there but
the laws are better in new jersey they
did the opposite the first thing i was
thinking is the opposite of new jersey
the laws are worse
so nobody wants to be there at all do
you think they collude the governments
like the new york government's like
don't make your state too much more
likeable than do much better than i'm
sure they do yeah those state
governments work with each other right
like especially if they're the same
party like they don't really want to be
screwing each other over that much
um and you know they work too they
especially think about things like
coveted regulations like they were all
working together all those like
connecticut new york jersey were like
working together to have uniform
regulations so they weren't losing
people and and honestly that's that's
one of the reasons that it was more
robust there than it was in like the dmv
right the district of columbia tried to
impose some like really restrictive
mandates and like but they weren't in
place in virginia and they weren't in
place in maryland so quickly dc found
out how to get rid of them because
otherwise they would just their
restaurants were empty i wonder why
maryland you know maryland is a really
great place you've got virginia west
virginia pennsylvania and dc and
delaware all of these different states
you could be like come bring your
business here instead they're like get
out maryland's really weird it is it's a
very strange case it's got to be
delaware delaware must have everybody on
the their boot on everyone's throat like
it's the it's the state where there's
like no corporate income tax delaware
and all every company is headquartered
in delaware like a p.o box it's like
some one old lady
delaware corporate law man they just
they they got way out ahead of it they
decided to make themselves very
favorable to business that's exactly
what they did they were nearby they were
on the isla delaware is like barely a
state
it's i mean it's basically they make
their money off of their their corporate
law like that's their that's their
industry in effect like that's what they
produce they produce good reliable
predictable corporate law and like
favorable business favorable environment
to be incorporated i just want to ask
people did did any of you actually ever
look at delaware it's not real it's not
it yeah it's not a real place it's like
a big city like look look at this look
i'm well it's like
they don't even have access to more than
they don't even have access to half of
the peninsula they're on it's like 12
acres it's like we're a peninsula but
only like a small part of it what what
is the other part of that peninsula what
state it's delmarva it's yeah so both
maryland and virginia have a chunk of
that peninsula so maryland is most of it
right but then that bottom little tail
is virginia they call it the delmarva
peninsula
and so delaware has this chunk that's it
that's all they have they couldn't even
get the peninsula they're on there's
like one city you don't go easy good
good though a lot of crab yeah great
seafood it's just seafront property just
a s a rich corporate person's dream i
guess yeah it depends it depends on
where you go rehoboth is very like
college i mean wilmington wilmington is
pretty cool that is such a weird thing
really great seafood but uh it's it's
it's you know what they're i'm pretty
sure
they're just funded by giving good
favorable laws to corporations and
everybody's always like what is it
delaware in nevada or something yeah
that has not worked in crypto oh it's
wyoming
cryptocurrency but you know some yeah
some some states are finally starting to
try and compete for like incorporation
rules it's just
now it's it's gotten to the point where
even if other states have like a little
bit better of like a financial deal for
incorporating in their state because
delaware corporate law is so well
developed that's where com bigger
companies want to be incorporated
because that's where they can get sued
so and that's where they have like the
big intra business disputes and so
everybody's just comfortable there's so
many more decisions so many so much
their law is just better developed and
so like that's where corporations do you
know when it began that they started
making it all about the corporation in
delaware i don't remember exactly when
it began but i know it's you know it
i don't know yeah actually i don't know
when that began that's it but i'm sure
there's books written on it and it's it
is really
sort of you know an interesting
like thing that a state like delaware
which otherwise would not have some big
thriving business industry just really
figured out and decided ah this is what
american capitalism needs a state that
really focuses on giving corporations
what they want in terms of both like a
friendly place to incorporate and
predictable law
and the people who run i mean the
lawyers they get who end up being on
like the delaware supreme court are like
top tier business attorneys like they
they're super super serious about it um
and and very very you know other places
you might get clowns and like family
members or whatever you the delaware
supreme court is notorious for having
like brilliant judges everybody's moving
to texas and i'm just like that's such a
bad idea
how come
so when
when big moderate types maybe the
anti-woke liberal type moves from
california or arizona or new york to
texas
they bring industry which is mostly full
of
these progressive left lib you know
cultists who then come down to work
there so the obvious thing is like joe
rogan for instance
he's a lefty dude but we all like him
he's pro free speech and he's he's
pushed back and he's done really great
and fighting against a lot of the the
excesses of the wokeness and and the
left but when he moves to texas
he brings industry with him and large
sums of money which
they're going to hire more hollywood
producers and la types and they're going
to all flock along with them elon musk
is an even better example
all of the tesla employees from
california he's going to have to he's
going to have to either rehire or
relocate a ton of those california
progressives into texas
so when i see all that happening and
austin's already particularly woke and
everyone's like austin's the place to be
i'm like i gotta admit austin's really
cool
but i would not
set a business there
you're basically saying i'm going to set
up my business there i'm going to move
there
i'm going to invest in this city and in
five years there's a good chance i will
just be surrounded by a bunch of people
who have voted for this stuff because
they all followed
i look at west virginia and i'm like
west virginia is the second most trump
supporting state in the country it is it
is maga country
and nobody wants to be there there's a
great so i'll go there and it'll stay in
my country and then i will hire people
who share the values that we have
liberty personal responsibility and
we'll create opportunity and bring
wealth to those who already agree the
thing about west virginia for me was
it's like here's this big open place
that's really got great good it's got
good laws it's got constitutional carry
it's got good building codes it's got
good business laws it's got uh great
incentives for new businesses and
nobody's gonna follow so that means when
we start hiring people when we start
contracting that's people of west
virginia who share values of personal
responsibility who are going to be
receiving that wealth not some woke
person who moved to austin to take that
job
that's that's the opportunity here go to
florida florida's great but i'm like
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna set
up and expand the economy in a place
where people aren't flocking to it and
it already has the values i like yeah
there's like a fake i get the the image
of when i think of west virginia i think
like walking out through hills which is
like hurts it's exhausting and then i
picture a dude in a red hat with a gun
and i'm like well
that's that's what i when i think about
i know it's not but that's like the
liberal brainwashing
people just have this idea man i took a
walk the other day
i'm close to west virginia right now and
i went up on a hill dude when you look
around from the top of a hill when
you're out in the middle of the in the
most beautiful
areas in the world i i would imagine
it's just so stunning in the air and
then the bear comes out heals you and be
sure you have bear spray i guess but it
was on a road so i didn't feel too just
even the drive up here was just gorgeous
today you know just driving through
rural virginia and
then the bear goes up to ian and says it
is time to prove yourself as i punch it
in the face and put my fingers down its
throat choking oh my gosh heavy metal
places i thought about bears what do you
do when a bear comes these days because
that's like you know the real threat is
wild animals and i guess humans are also
animals but like
you just don't let them take your picnic
basket yeah that's right you have to
stand firm you got to be not leave food
out it's like another lifestyle if you
run he won't respect you thinking about
bears and stuff like yogi bear was kind
of a crazy show yeah it was still a
picnic basketball but but that's all he
was doing he was like he was like a
nuisance and in the reality if you like
chased after a bear because you stole
your picnic basket you'd probably just
maul you were murdering yeah i mean
let the picnic basket go at that point
depends on the bear i guess what do they
say for like grizzlies you got to curl
up and cover your neck but for black
bears you got to fight
well you also have to understand that
yogi is smarter than the average bear
and so i would assume that means he has
like some understanding of maybe
firearms the fact that humans can shoot
him but either way it's it's preventing
him from getting violent with people we
haven't seen it yogi yeah we haven't
seen yogi in any of the cartoons can you
imagine because a bear can really just
destroy somebody dude i've never seen he
wanted to ranger rick would like be
obliviated it would just
i saw grizzly man i highly recommend you
ever see
old bear armor yeah look at this
it's like a russian this is like their
stuff is this russian or something it's
probably
i can't imagine that they really wore
something like that yeah man what do you
when you got no choice
there's a thing called the short-nosed
bear it's extinct now let me see if i
can find a bear armor bear i feel like
you would still get destroyed if a bear
smacked you like it would hurt the bear
right but they're strong one of those
things smacks you it'll pretty sure a
grizzly can hit a car door and smack it
clean off the car yeah
and like you need really large caliber
rounds to even
hurt a bear
jeez yeah like there was a there was a
grizzly they they found i can't remember
where i was bringing the story and they
finally killed it and it was riddled
with like 45 9 millimeter just because
from people shooting at it and the
bullets just like going in and doing
nothing the grizzlies like you cannot
harm me
feeble human weapons that's terrifying
um
sean connery
i don't know because that's because you
know bears are masculine
well i will take bears over a bunch of
hungry people i honestly in this at this
point in my life i'm i'd rather not face
a bear so i'm not going to say that what
i was going to say which is i'd rather
face a bear than i'd rather not face a
bear but i just you know that's life
that's life there was a story recently
of a dude who just fought a bear
he fought a bear off with his bare hands
with his bare hands say her hands
something happened i can't remember and
there was like a bear came and he had to
fight it for his family and then he won
dudes built
bears are crazy man yeah check out
grizzly man and have you guys seen
grizzly man
no it's a documentary this guy went into
the woods he was obsessed with bears and
they thought well i think there's
something wrong with this guy but he
went with his girlfriend and lived with
the bears you know and then they said
okay you can live with bears i guess
don't do it but i guess but not when
they're not when they're hungry not when
they're getting just out of hibernation
yeah but he was like no they're my
friends
and it's it's a werner herzog movie dude
and you get the audio of him screaming
why would he think that i don't know
it's like it's like he had a death wish
you hear his girlfriend screaming fight
back fight back on the audio and it's
like he was just i don't know there's no
video of it the cap the lens cap was on
when it got recorded thank goodness and
then what happened to the his was a wife
she was then killed by the bear as well
she didn't run no i don't know but i
mean i guess they were out in the middle
of the woods there's really nowhere to
run to i don't to be honest i don't know
maybe they would have both had death
wish it's a weird thing to be doing
hanging out with bears when they're
hungry i'm just imagining these two
hippies being like yo like the bears are
my friends man that's what it was the
bear was smalling the guy like yo why
are you mauling joey what are you doing
no why are you biting me now oh i'm
being eaten by a bear rather i try to be
too insensitive because i think he has
family and stuff but like he is
screaming like stop ow ow stop you can
hear it it's so weird
as he's being torn open yeah it's
horrific the bear is just like free
lunch yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there